in five four three two one
what's going on everybody over here on
your daily commute and no matter what
you're doing you already know genius
brain is right next to you sucking your
teat I posted on Instagram right now
about genius brain in your [ __ ] face
man I am your host David show and I'm
your other host Joe Jitsu kala and we
have uh sometimes once in a while
gasps host mr. Nick a very special guy
sup everybody how are you
also known as goblin goblin goblin or
why why do you call him Goblin because
because people say I look like one we
have this uh so you know how Yoshi
trains with us all the time and so we
had this like joke that we're gonna do a
buddy cop movie or it's just too ugly
guys just be a dick Goblin an orc yeah
that's a pretty dope combo I think so
a good cop bad cop but it just ugly cop
and exactly who goes into auditions and
never gets booked I want to play the
Asian dad the disapproving agent that
Commissioner Commissioner John oh you be
a lieutenant let me tie it lieutenant
we'd always [ __ ] up yeah give me a
[ __ ] bad Goblin in or yeah damn it
not again you guys [ __ ] up and I'm like
did the last time yeah so we've been uh
so this has been a heavy top you know I
don't even really want to talk about I
didn't think that this would be a great
podcast topic but everybody's so curious
about our opinions on Game of Thrones
what are you talking about it's an
amazing topic I adamantly did not watch
Game of Thrones okay forever
I want to ask you why I wanna you know
you fought us so hard for the last
three-plus years reason when we kept
telling your ass to watch Game of
Thrones I didn't want to watch it
because you wanna watch it in one week
because because the because I watched
the few and I actually read the first
book or Marin I can't remember my ninth
one or two I can't remember but it was
so long ago because the book came out
long time ago yeah but when I was
watching this show it just wasn't that
great that's what happens that when you
read the book first it always ruins it
hey I'm single I've never seen anything
where I've read the book first and I'm
like ah man yeah and I think it was just
so slow and there was so much thing and
I couldn't remember everything from the
book so I you know it was just like
watching with a fresh pair of eyes right
and then the show takes work though like
just you have to remember everyone's
names like you said they they they take
they have so many new characters they're
introducing all the time yeah so that's
what it was it was Brienne of Tarth it
was this from Target I was like yeah
what the [ __ ] there's so many characters
now you know what names but the titties
made you just like so much Oh teddy okay
okay let's get back to the show dude
with Melisandre the the nicest titties
of all the river service to us those are
her [ __ ] titties dude you know what I
found out that disappointed me so
throughout the all of the seasons right
now mind you I never got to see Circe's
titties you know Circe's guy [ __ ]
it's a TD double yes they showed I
thought their shows are luscious titties
dude it was CGI to know don't they they
have titty doubles for her to really
yeah in the first episode that wasn't on
the first episode I think later she it
was in a writer in a later season
obviously she's the one who's most
importantly you got to see
Theon's dead did you see his dick fianc
dick though when you guys pluck a dick
cut off from him before that don't they
show his dick cut off see they didn't
actually shows dude yeah but it was like
in the first season you see Dion's dick
okay the saddest moment yeah yeah cuz
they foreshadowed it so early they knew
who's gonna get his dick cut off I saw
when when cuz Tim told me that it wasn't
Circe's actually titties and that made
that scene ten times worse was that's a
shame one yeah shame shame because she's
an older woman but she's [ __ ] fine
dude yeah she's fine as hell but then
her real titties might be disappointing
I know and that those two got luscious
young titties
year old delicious as a dumpling today
it was I asked eighties there was a good
age to them it is funny because when
when people were trying to get me to
watch the show to telling me the biggest
reason why I should watch it was because
of the titties after a while you just
don't care about them it's all the
reason to watch that show yeah that's
that's what I like about the shows
there's there's many layers right I mean
you know you when you watch content you
can watch it for the titty you could
watch it for the action you go watch it
for the drama you could watch it for it
and that's what makes a good show is
because everyone can enjoy it for
different reasons oh yeah because when I
was watching it all I could think about
was after a while when the story started
getting good around like the second or
third season I was like dude move these
titties out the way let's let's continue
the story yeah yeah like in what a
ballsy move that they killed Ned Stark
in the first season like I thought first
time I saw that I was like this is a
[ __ ] joke I knew they were going to
kill I had no idea I didn't read the
books so it was like and I was like five
years late I just didn't like the very
predictable foreshadowing for example
when they had Daenerys Targaryen in the
very first scene right where her [ __ ]
freaky ass brother takes off her dress
is [ __ ] and this is that boiling hot
water bath and she steps into it I might
buy something with dragons my dad
dragged yeah yeah she goes over my head
I had no [ __ ] home and I'm not really
like critical like when I watch stuff I
don't critique it at first I never do I
just watched to enjoy it how whoever
directs it wants me to watch it but then
there was a lot of stuff that just kind
of like okay like when they just kept
popping up and it distracted you yeah so
like when they threw the kid over when
they threw bran over I was like he's
gonna throw him out the window right and
he throws him out and everybody that was
so shocking right I don't think so I
love his character development was
really great because Jaime Lannister I
hated his guts but then you start to
feel bad for him after a while because
he doesn't even want to be considered a
Kingslayer like that that title was
actually something that kind of made him
feel really bad because he lusted for
Cersei yeah so tight and then the other
thing that was the opposite is brans
character development because you
[ __ ] hate him at the end of the
seasons what could he so [ __ ] worse
this was brand all right this is this is
haven't seen the latest episode this is
what this episode is so shits going down
alright spoiler alert shits going down
people are dying the brand goes I'm
going to walk everyone's protecting this
is all for you [ __ ] and then
you're ditching your own birthday party
basically yeah yeah it's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing he sends the damn
clothes out he goes out and [ __ ]
hangs that like he goes on his drone
basically this fool flies often is drone
to do what I don't know I everybody get
murdered yeah first hand but then the
thing too is like when I saw him award I
was like oh he's good this is what we've
been waiting for he does something cool
that [ __ ] could at least used the crow
to poke out a [ __ ] White Walkers I he
was like oh here's the night king and
then that was it that was it he just
goes excuse me
and he disappears for a [ __ ] excuse me
how were you for six hours you [ __ ]
[ __ ] back but the theory you brought up
today that makes me think that like it
was on purpose yes I wanna I hope that's
what it is if it's not then they wasted
this all this character for no reason
like for him to have to just warg into
the crows and then that'd be it I don't
know what else they're gonna do it so
for people who don't know there's a lot
of like random theories that are flowing
floating up and so I kind of googled I
forgot what I googled but it left led to
this theory where there there's a theory
that bran is actually there's two so it
kind of goes hand in hand where they
think that bran is actually the night
king because he can go back in forth and
time and so he was actually confronting
himself and the reason why people think
that is because wouldn't a three-eyed
raven is the night king yeah oh but
here's the weird part and the reason why
that kind of gets debunked it's because
you could actually see this scene where
the forest people they put the dragon
class into that person that wasn't brand
yeah but then he has the ability to
change the past or whatever to a certain
extent and so what they're saying is
that bran is actually evil and he was
meeting up with the night king and when
he warden to those Ravens he was
actually communicating with the night
king he's for sure evil dude yeah his
sophist Arya was the one that actually
ruined brand's plan because that wasn't
expected that cunning little bit good
eye you know what was [ __ ] with
everything I forgot because when you
first watch the episode she's ten years
old yeah but I know
she had this scene when she got naked
like look and she looks exactly the same
she looks a little taller yeah she seems
like a little boy but long hair what the
[ __ ] but then I guess in this show she's
like 22 well what was weird to me is
like she you know how she was like
sexually forward with the dude and then
it just felt like she was just this
jailbait mmm and she was like I'm about
to she was like she I even though she
was the predator it was just weird she
couldn't wait she said I need some dick
to see how it feels like
and in that scene where she's just
laying there it like you could totally
see the disappointment in her face like
that was it
she felt like hmm I probably like puss
there was a there was a mean that says
when winter came but you didn't this is
what I waited for yeah yeah that's
hilarious that's there's a couple of
moments in this show now magic because I
was I wasn't against watching as I tried
and I didn't like it but then it was
difficult for you because you couldn't
get through the house slow the first two
seasons but yeah it takes work dude yeah
it does like you don't start realizing
that you like it until a couple of
episodes in yeah if you do not get to
the red wedding and you are missing out
that is one of the most iconic moments
in the whole series because I've never
met you know what if you say like look
this is gonna be a bunch of spoilers and
if you haven't seen it it's been out for
eight years you cut back so anyways so
[ __ ] I've never seen somebody put out
a scene where somebody stabs up a fetus
pregnant lady in the sky but it was a
spirit fetus so it was okay yeah they
showed it to that was like the first
thing they showed wasn't her just
getting stabbed in the gut and I've
never seen somebody stab somebody that
fast that repeats it so much so violent
dude so violent I had nightmares I like
PTSD after watching that that was a
[ __ ] rough episode okay so what do
you think um happen at the end you know
how like the the [ __ ] red lit like
lady she went out she walked out to the
[ __ ] oh so that she sacrificed
herself to the Sun God and [ __ ] I think
that was a good redemption for her well
that was hate that [ __ ] I think that
was it was just her job is done now so
show that I can because I mean [ __ ] is
like 3,000 years old you know she's like
a [ __ ] disgusting gremlin who you
know wanted by the way I so want to [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of her
she's gotta keep the necklace audible no
that [ __ ] look like [ __ ] Gollum and
[ __ ] like yes I not take the necklace
off that thing was a big shock or two I
was like what does she do oh my I forgot
about home I literally forgot about her
I didn't think she'd be coming back in
the season but she was hot though yeah I
mean it was funny because when she's
walking into the scene it seems like a
white Walker messengers coming yeah and
then it's not your turn dude should i
that's cool
okay I'll just make sure I talk really
close okay thank God your sounds good I
could hear it in here okay I might I
think I sound low I don't know if you
yes I don't know okay test test test
okay I don't know did I sound regular -
yeah he's ornery okay yeah but yeah the
show has so many twists and turns and I
think you kind of get emotionally
involved with certain characters and
they keep killing them off who did you
think should have died - sad well
[ __ ] started reveille he [ __ ] you
killed no way he survived to the end he
for sure sure he is i someone told me
the books are from his point of view oh
that's always the [ __ ] that survived
because he's a Meister get rid of them
yeah he's the [ __ ] Meister that's why
so he's the one useless brother keep him
alive so he could ride it all that's
right they should just call it [ __ ]
the well if he's writing the books then
they should just call it why everybody
died because of me why I didn't do
anything to help yeah he does nothing
dude and he keeps holding on to the fact
that he killed a nightwalker by chance
and he keeps holding on to the fact that
he killed a [ __ ] then by chance yeah
the [ __ ] out of here get out of here bro
you know seems to forget I was the first
one to kill a white Walker chance you by
you got lucky
Sam a little Gilly cuz even the way he
even had a moment where he quote/unquote
stood up to his dad right so he goes
he's like [ __ ] this thing I'm out of my
dad's castle or whatever he takes the
the the Valyrian steel sword but he has
to do it like a [ __ ] way he was even
fun as dad hides out in the middle of
night and run
him and then when he finds out that
Daenerys killed his brother and his dad
he's like oh really
he was so polite like it was his fault
yeah I've never seen somebody's lip
quiver for ten minutes it goes up yeah
remember that scene when all is all
[ __ ] up and it's kind of like this
montage and you see him in a body of
White Walkers shivering like a little
[ __ ] yep and I'm like you should have
died
yeah dude how did that guy survive
everybody got mad at me on Twitter I was
like I [ __ ] hate Samwell Tarly hate
him
what's the yeah I like him cuz I hate
him okay I like him cuz he's such a
little [ __ ] I want to keep him around
to laugh at him I remember earlier in
the seasons I was like why are we going
back to the dude like any time they
would you know it was story Oh rounds
the show so if everyone's a heroic tough
guy or whatever there's no reality or
Norma see so you need that guy to
represent how crazy battles are and all
that that's true there was also this
other theory which was kind of
interesting so you know how it's was it
the men I thought not the man from
nowhere the man with no face right yeah
with oh yeah the sexy guy heard along
yet so you know you know him right yeah
there's a theory saying that remember
her original dance partner that the
sword guy yeah the curly-haired
flatpoint they're saying that that is
actually that might actually be the
faceless man that will be so tired
because if you look at that scene so he
kicks everybody's ass right and if you
go back to a scene where you were there
talking about who's the guy who got his
face burned what's his name
oh that big guy yeah a hound so clicking
Clegane right so the game
so remember there was a scene where Arya
was speaking to Clegane and he was
asking her who's on her list yeah as she
mentions the guy who she eventually you
know gouges his eyes out and [ __ ] in the
brothel but she mentioned that oh I want
to kill the guy who killed my master and
he mentions his name and then clicking
was like him he sucks like what the [ __ ]
like what do you mean like you're saying
your sword master got killed by that guy
so how was this guy who was like the
best sword guy in all of Westeros he
died on purpose they think that he
didn't die just do that was actually the
faceless man and so he probably escaped
but who died them so that you didn't get
to see who died because she ran away and
all you
the fighting so the theory is that that
person is actually the faceless man dude
that'd be tyre if they revealed that her
sword teacher yeah yeah because how is
this guy the the man who was the best
swordsman so then when she was at the
monastery the faceless the death
monastery yeah I think that the faceless
man was actually that guy yes something
else no this what they're saying that
the teacher was the faceless man yeah oh
yeah be dubbed as they were so mean
yeah you didn't get to see him actually
die you saw him beat everybody up with
that wooden sword and then click gain
actually confirmed that the the person
that she later on killed wasn't even
dope like he was not about that yeah
yeah but I was a [ __ ] dude they were
good yeah with the [ __ ] ball stick
did bar was saying that they've been
prepping her to be able to do all this
stuff because they knew first years ago
that she was gonna kill the night king
Wow prepping her so did you guys
remember that whole scene when the red
lady was telling her blue eyes like yeah
I was like ooh blue eyes I thought she
was gonna go kill a bunch of White
Walkers yeah and then I totally forgot
when she came back it was like all blue
eyes I didn't know that until someone
told me that she that's what she said
why do you do did you understand the
thing before she was saying like green
eyes brown eyes yeah and in blue eyes
remember that yeah brown eyes is what a
little little finger I was it's a little
snake yeah right I then green eyes I
think was supposed to be if you go on
Twitter saying Circe
if you go on Twitter you could see this
clip of of Arya at Brienne of Tarth
practicing the sparring [ __ ] where they
were where they were sparring with in
Winterfell where she did that knife flip
as she caught it as she put it - bro
that's [ __ ] clean did she actually
did in real life where she does the flip
grabs the knife and put Stuart throat
damn [ __ ] gangster dude art is pretty
far did jumper having sex I don't wanna
see that yeah I never want to see that
everyone but she's you know how all that
one tough ass [ __ ] that little girl
that got crushed by the giant
what's-her-name [ __ ] lady more money
more money interesting up in both scenes
her and Arya kind of did the whole same
situation oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they were caught and then things suck in
ish like that dude I thought they were
she was gonna
her face eaten I was like dude I was
covering my eyes like I don't want to
see this I don't see this do lady
Mormont that little girl I thought she
was so doped to the point she was gonna
spin off on her own show yeah I was
thinking they killed her off she was
know some people hate her I don't a lot
of people hate her why there's a little
[ __ ] yeah she's annoying you know what
who hates her [ __ ] sexist okay right
misogynist that's what they I just like
seeing kids in powerful roles yeah cuz I
mean dad used to happen like you know
like there was a king like a like a kid
king and the dad died or whatever and
it's like or no that's that Chinese
movie the [ __ ] Last Emperor what dad
to check his [ __ ] and all that stuff
yeah but then you get a shot that's
that's that's that's why people don't
like kid kings yeah in this universe is
cuz you look at King Joffrey you're like
dude [ __ ] that guy I was looking at like
a montage of King Joffrey and I was like
dude that because it make you wonder
like why did why does an adult just
[ __ ] slap that fool aside and then
take over it's so easy yeah that's what
we're doing anyways yeah that's true
they were just running in circles well
by actually who so who was who was the
character that you guys hated the most
so far throughout the whole series oh I
would say Jeffery and um a little bit a
little finger only because I thought he
was a good guy and I felt like he
backstab me personally I personally felt
like I was like you [ __ ] [ __ ] I was
like now we were on the same team team
you know me you hit him up on Twitter
you you broke he's a [ __ ] little finger
I felt like little finger was like
helping Santa everybody like he was
still like a stark team start kind of
guy but he's team little finger that's
all he looks out for little [ __ ] yeah
big selfish talk to you that's not true
I think Joffrey for sure but now it's
brand
I [ __ ] hate brand new I hate brand
just because he stares off into space
like and he's the most powerful
[ __ ] but he doesn't say [ __ ]
he's still creepy like if you already
know the future why don't you just
[ __ ] help they should had a little
chasing of like the night king coming
after brand and he just like goes down a
slope this [ __ ] little figure is the
character I hate the most
and Samwell well Sam Tarly is a close
second but the reason why I hate
Littlefinger is because I have everybody
he's the second yeah [ __ ] Joffrey
gets a pass so little cuz you know what
he he is a victim of affluenza that's
his true he is a victim of affluenza cuz
what I'm thinking - yeah just [ __ ] made
kind of it's like I if for in order for
me to hate Joffrey and then I also have
to hate Tommen and you know and Tommen
is he's he commented was just born into
a very bad situation but the reason why
I hate [ __ ] Peter base there's a
couple of things he looks like a rapist
number two for sure really he talks to
people as close as his my keys to my
face I [ __ ] hate it dude he just
Sansa
sons a star okay Sansa I've always loved
you and your mother your mother you know
it's been a while since I've seen you
sense like you've grown so much you have
a choice answer you could keep running
for the rest of your life or you could
finally make a stand like first of all
deed back the [ __ ] away from my face you
2 inch face talker
dude he's he's so manipulative - I was a
little disappointed in how he got killed
though I thought I thought they were
gonna milk out his death at all I
thought that was dope how they kind of
flip the script on him though so I was
like oh you you've learned Santa good
girl and then you teamed up did you see
his like just levels of denial well he
was just kind of acting like he didn't
know what was going on that he went to
anger then he wanted a pen yeah he did
each I know I see yeah you'd none of you
have proof none of you that fool is a
[ __ ] snake though okay but that's
pretty gangster how Sansa does kind of
hurt you know yeah life cuz he helped
her yeah well he was doing it because he
wanted to get something it was yeah it
came out at yeah that's true see he was
using her the whole time he gambled way
too much and he [ __ ] lost it didn't
kill her aunt - right yeah yeah I went
through the [ __ ] little [ __ ]
little titty sucking kid - yeah that was
dude that was so weird I didn't like
that that whole sequence the little
titty sucking ah dude I was like get rid
of it I don't want to see that that was
definitely a prosthetic tit
oh sure sure because that little
ten-year-old was sucking on that tit
like it was nothing
do but hearse her nights were like
[ __ ] pristine yeah remember those
guys yeah those guys were like they had
the most expensive
armored and all that [ __ ] look dope yeah
that's white my favorite character
though has to be Tyrion Lannister that's
fine too yeah he's just so smart yeah I
like him he's like despite all these
handicaps that he has like number one
his dad [ __ ] hates him yeah he's
marked him killed him on a toilet
- I feel crossbow dude when his [ __ ]
[ __ ] backstabbed him that was she was
paid since the beginning no does she
love him no right the one that he
married I'm not sure I think he did love
her I think she did love him but she was
so dumb
yeah she didn't understand why he was
asking her to go away so she felt
backstab that's how dumb she is she was
just so sorry I totally forgot about I
need to watch her dad his dad that he
found out his dad paid her to do all
this bullsh oh is that what happened I
thought I thought it just [ __ ] her I
thought she I thought she did that just
because she felt betrayed
oh man I'm I'm mixing [ __ ] up what do
you think what are your predictions for
the next couple episodes number one I I
think it's gonna be revealed that Arya
was she did that faceless thing with one
of the White Walkers cuz if you looked
in the scene before she jumped out there
was one of the generals that moved his
head this way and then Ari had jumped
out so I'm thinking that she used that
faceless technique with actors to trip
them out
yep you know what I thought was gonna
happen too is that I didn't know that
the one guy was the leader of all the
White Walkers I thought you had to kill
every single general no no I would've
had so it's all like what how it works
is whoever's rows up whoever you just
got to get that source so remember there
was a scene of Luhrmann's game yeah it's
the worst pyramid scheme ever exactly so
when Jon Snow killed one did the the the
what little generals a whole bunch of
them died so if they raised those people
then they will die so he raced everybody
else so if you kill the main guy and
everybody so wire Walker pyramid scheme
is the worst pyramid scheme ever it's it
was it was pretty [ __ ] Chris like I
didn't expect I did not expect him to
die in that episode okay I saw some
other theories saying that yeah I didn't
think I didn't think they they should
have killed him off so early but I don't
know maybe what does a show go exactly
it's like what are we gonna go back to
the throne now like yeah it seems like a
little trivial but
a theory saying about how Aria might
become the power might transfer to her
because she's the one that killed him
the white Walker no she might be the
next white queen you know I mean but I
don't know if that's I think your theory
makes a lot more sense yeah I don't know
where do they go with that what does
that reveal about brand do they just
[ __ ] mark brand or do they set him on
fire please someone to set him on fire
well the worst right it's cool it's not
brand anymore because remember when John
came in for a hug he knew yes like oh
you smelled different you [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah we're actually looking
for Ford for the the the Circe's thing
to wrap up I want to see what's gonna
happen there that's probably gonna be
the next episode she kills everybody
that idea but I don't know if she has a
powerful enough army whoa hey be think
about think about the army they have now
they don't have [ __ ] all right cuz yeah
yeah yeah for sure one of the dragons
are gonna die at least one or is gonna
die because they got a dragon they keep
hyping up the [ __ ] dragon launcher
that they have oh I just thing and then
they have the Navy that the golden coast
army or whatever but here's here's what
I think is gonna happen that's gonna
blow everybody away is Jon Snow and
[ __ ] Denarius de neighs is gonna want
the fun when she her whole life she
wants to number one yeah she might get
into some [ __ ] like he might have to
accidentally kill her like she might
have to like come after him because when
when she when he broke the news like yo
I just [ __ ] to you my cousin yeah I'm
actually the rifle King John Snow
doesn't wanna be the the remaining he's
wanted King ever never
that's why for John getting the position
right so he might be the default King
because Denarius is still power-hungry
and what the show does is like oh if you
want something so [ __ ] bad yeah and
if it's yeah and if you're too shady
about it or whatever they take away yeah
he's just I feel it's crazy how his
story developed so much because he
literally was at the bottom of the
[ __ ] totem pole and he just kept
climbing in the pasture and he doesn't
want to yeah he doesn't want to collect
Forrest Gump dude he just keeps making
it he's so lovable everyone likes him
yeah and whatever what if that happens
though it ends with maybe John being the
king and Daenerys never gets a role she
might even die in his
we see the way around or they just get
married and in their power couple but
that's just too [ __ ] simple I don't
know if we play out that way I think
John dies if John dies I'm killing
everybody so who do you think is gonna
be the actual king of the realm King
Jorah no Torres Lord Baelish Varys
perished Varys dude that I feel bad for
Jorah because he [ __ ] loved Daenerys
so much I know that fool was so thirsty
that gold season although all the new
guys that come into her life all sleep
with her
yeah and this fool gets bragging that
guy is a definition of friends died
saving her yeah died saving her he gives
her life he doesn't even get one [ __ ]
lick do they not even a lake tastes 70
years old dude whatever Ozzy thinking
you gotta give your boy some play though
a dedicate his life to her hey when you
touch that might too much I'm sorry
you son of a [ __ ] oh my bad what was
wrestling with it I'm just like is it a
snake you don't want to place you
[ __ ] [ __ ] this was like okay
what's gonna do here should I put on my
head episode they're gonna be like why
the [ __ ] is that guy touching the mic so
goddamn much alright can you hear it
what are you doing it keeps any closer
to me and my [ __ ] nervous tic dude
it's fine
I'm guys just grab my dick though much
cos like touch my dick ball time me too
I would be okay I bet I'm fine I
actually like to binge game it like like
last season I wish I just binge did
because to me it was like it was good
after but after the battle like I didn't
it cools off yeah I'm like okay I
could've been to this in one season but
this one except for the first episode
I'm I'm like okay [ __ ] yeah
every single one I'm in No Deal I don't
like the first episode this is people
are like oh my god it was so great it
was the first time people met I'm like
I'll give a [ __ ] yeah
everyone looked at them all weird when
they came in to like Winterfell the
first episode I mean a lot of it was
build up there just building up to that
one battle necessary yeah yeah set up
the wrap ups you have to tie loose ends
for story I get it it's necessary but
damn they [ __ ] milk that [ __ ] baby
the [ __ ] out of that who do you think
ends up on the throne in the end one
person I mean if you wanna if you want
to be predict like like generally I
think it's gonna be Jon Snow like that's
that's what everyone thinks right yeah
what will be dope though is if it ends
up being Tyrion Oh
because they were saying that he might
be a Targaryen yeah there's a chance
he's a Targaryen yeah why just because
he is a bastard isn't he no he's not a
bastard but he might be like cheated
like the wife was cheating oh that's one
right that's right that's right I know
that's I don't think that's that's a
deep one yeah that's it's like season
four limits in that for a while I wasn't
why his dad kept like denying him or
whatever he's like yeah but it's also
cuz you know I person III assumed for
some reason that all Targaryen would be
able to withstand fire oh yeah that was
another reason why they said with Tyrion
but her brother remember
Daenerys his brother yeah he couldn't
stand withstand fire they melted over
his face in his die so hood its heat
though she could he was steady heat
because well that's true because water
the hot water or whatever yeah I don't
know maybe she's because she's the
chosen mother of dragons yeah cuz I
wonder if Jon Snow can was dead fire
then - yeah cuz that's what I was
wondering
that was [ __ ] fire nice yo he's really
short apparently really if you if you
Peary and Lannister cuz they kept the
house cuz they kept making short it you
know short jokes at John and then when
you lose John yeah I could instead
without be very sensitive me but if you
look at of stand next to uh to Daenerys
he's actually not that much taller than
her everybody says it Aries is short
yeah yeah apparently he has to wear
heels like everyone's like making fun of
them about it they're saying that like
he has to wear like heels on the show
to be taller and they have to shoot it a
certain way so he looks like he's taller
I mean he's not the first short action
story Tom Cruise he's 5/8 every agents
that happen yeah alone like me and
Stallone are the same height oh really
yeah I thought Sloane was tallest [ __ ]
oh he's that's what he looks like he's
like 5 6 dude he's like my seven five
six yeah yeah I'm like five seven ish
five six and a half the half really
counts when you're around that five yeah
you're that five five yeah
well I'll tell you well not like five
seven five eight with shoes on baby
pretty much the same yeah it's it's yeah
but you know Sun King right yeah he did
action movie with them and then he was
like they're doing a scene and then he
says like he was laughs he was just on
Kings a funny [ __ ] dude yeah
roast a lot of people he said that fool
[ __ ] came out of his actors trailer and
all of a sudden he's like the same
height and he's wearing platform shoes
and in today it is this like person a
she goes would you think I'm gonna let
you be smaller than me or you think I'm
gonna let you be taller than me
there's my movie that's fine dude what
the hell Wow he has custom shoes yeah
that's so weird crazy that this guy's
like all odds were against him he has
like [ __ ] that that not cerebral
palsy but [ __ ] balls Paul Bell's
palsy yeah but his face is [ __ ]
paralyzed this was five six that food
speaks with a slur and he still became
the action star man dude dude there was
that whole story behind him not wanting
to sell the original Rocky screenplay
for the longest time and I forgot what
the the amount of money was but during
this time he was so poor he was living
out of his car he sold his dog in order
to get some money and then people were
coming up to him because they liked his
script so much that they would buy a
first certain amount and mind you at
that time there was a lot of money but I
mean I just order number I was like
fifty thousand dollars or something
right whatever during that time is
probably like a hundred thousand and he
just wouldn't sell it he wouldn't sell
the script because he wanted to direct
it he wanted to own it and he also
wanted to be one of the main character
dude what a long shot when I hear
stories like that I'm like that's why
I'm not number
they believe in that I don't believe in
my pleasure
if someone gives me 10 grand I can take
it take right now imagine yours buddy
and then you he tells you that that's
the deal he got and then he was like I
didn't take it
you'd be like are you [ __ ] stupid I
was like you get out of my [ __ ] house
right now he deserve to live in that car
get the [ __ ] out of here I thank you
you'll never be anybody and I think when
he got the money back he actually bought
his dog back yeah when he grant or some
[ __ ] for his dog that's crazy that's
dope don't saw your dog though you know
yeah keep your dog and I guess [ __ ] you
could sell the the original rocky if you
notice there was a scene where they were
coming up and down the stairs or some
[ __ ] like that in his apartment complex
but that was where one of the first
gimble's was ever created on the rocky
set like a camera gimbal yes so they
never had like this steady shot that
would counterbalance the weight from the
camera to how you would walk and you
would bounce and I guess if I'm remember
this correctly but that was like where
the first game was created it was on the
Rocky movie and I'm completely wrong I
just wasted everybody saying that's I
though either way let's just keep it
that way yeah we're just gonna say its
truth yeah it happened I like the mist
the magic behind it so let's just keep
it true yeah Rocky is actually one of my
favorite films the first one only good
yeah you don't like rocky for that rocky
for three that's three three is it yeah
you're right three humus of tea that's
that one's cool but Drago I don't know
the Drago well maybe that is for iron
there was five total okay so wait
there's the original Rocky original one
was it Hollow
yep second one was was it mr. t mr. t
mr. t and the third one was Drago Drago
Drago kills and the fourth one was with
Tommy Gunn
but what terrible one I don't remember
that one do that one was [ __ ]
terrible so it's it's more about I want
to say it's terrible it's just more of
his development as a human being and how
he was trying to learn how to be without
the boxing thing
boring and so to see him fight and so
for him he trained this kid Tommy gun at
the time Tommy Gunn was a real boxer too
so the they casted him for it and
basically Tommy Gunn was this you know
poor kid and he took him under his wing
and then Tommy Gunn decided to backstab
him went with a different promoter
different different trainer
and it just [ __ ] up their relationship
and it was kind of highlighting how
rocky still want he can't step away from
fighting no matter what and so there's
like a scene where he's his his kids
resents him he ends up like crying in
front of Adrian and [ __ ] like that and
just gets all emotional but it was it
wasn't that great in the movie yeah but
he beats up tommy gun in the middle of a
in a parking lot or an out in the middle
of his neighborhood in the street food
bare-knuckles sounds boring I don't
remember that you guys remember best of
the best
yeah you guys remember those movies was
have bits and pieces of it oh really oh
man I thought you guys for sure remember
those movies with Philip Bri and Simon
Reid yeah they're brothers it's kind of
like imagine bloodsport it's like that
but then it's like Street Fighter Tam I
haven't seen that [ __ ] I just love
bloodsport feed most out of all the
[ __ ] cool films I've ever seen in my
life and she makes no sense it's time
just watched it know like it's my
favorite oh yeah yeah yeah blood works
pretty dope yeah you gotta watch best
the best you know why I like blood of
the best because I liked Street Fighter
the videogame oh yeah yeah kind of
reminded me like like you know you just
had these stereotypical weird characters
we had a sumo guy or the big Mongolian
guy yeah unki that was jumping around
and like it was funny yeah yeah but when
I watched blood I remember just blood
sport was one of those things where
there was a couple of movies that I saw
because I watched it on public
television I didn't realize how [ __ ]
bloody it was yeah bloodsport was and
also Robocop Robocop dude the originator
to firt to put on TV yeah oh man
homie got his legs blown off in the
first place seen his B got his spirit
blown out of his body good those just
chunks of his body flying out and I
remember when I first saw it without the
censorship on VHS yeah you get it from
Blockbuster you watch the first time and
you're like oh I don't want to watch
this movie
yeah remember at the end where he has
the sniper and he blows everyone up and
then they start like I think the one guy
gets covered an acid it's all man it's
looking bad acid comes out it destroys
him oh dude that was really bad the dad
from that 70 show is the guy at red he's
the guy that blows everybody and calls
this Winslow
with that yeah he's the cop yeah I can't
remember we gotta watch that yeah I just
remember my dad made like the corniest
joke one time just based off a Robocop
reference it was hey I want my friends
and then this is when I was like wait
treating is [ __ ]
and then my dad comes up to my friends
the dumbest [ __ ] joke my dad always
makes stupid jokes he just goes look at
my son he's a like a Robocop my name is
Amir pee dude yeah we had this pastor
back in the day I don't know what's with
Korean people and referencing all these
like 80s like movies but there was this
pastor now mind you when I went to uh I
went to this church called skp see
sacrament of Korean Presbyterian Church
it's like one of the biggest Korean
churches in Sacramento right now but
there was a passion that they brought
over he was a Korean fob had a Japanese
wife both them he can't speak Japanese
and she can't speak Korean but they said
but they said I'm Mary
I think they communicated through like
the Spirit of Christ the Holy Spirit
that's what I can remember that always
blows my mind I don't get it as a
husband and wife and they can't even
speak each other's like how often does
that happen though I've seen it a couple
times
it's just weird so I was like I just
always make jokes like basically all
they do is just there's just they wanna
[ __ ] they just kind of do the hanging
and then but this fool he was so weird
because he wanted to relate to us as
young people so he made all these stupid
references that were just dumb like I
remember was in like the 2000s and he's
like talking about like some 80 [ __ ]
like terminator [ __ ] so I remember he's
I'll be back
I would always cry laughing because of
how corny he was he once started off a
sermon referencing terminator you know
that first thing when he's butt-naked
and he's laying down yeah he just starts
the sermon on his knees with his fists
to the pole oh my he just he gets up
slowly and he goes Jesus is like a
terminator [ __ ] is this guy and that was
one of his first sermons that he had in
our church but he's right though
if I had my church I can I bother be
going still to this day yeah I was his
like terminator
I just I wish I would have wrote down
how many weird references he had but he
made like this really insensitive one
about Native Americans
and animals or some [ __ ] but he was like
it's like a Native American and how they
like a worshipper eagle and it's like
you want to apply in the air like a
Jesus just do the sermon in Korean dude
this is terrible nobody understands you
dude it's like it's like a terminator
it's like I come back from a picture and
he was so serious about that [ __ ] I
[ __ ] hate that guy he's so weird it's
funny but isn't there a lot of old
people like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about yeah he eventually got
fired and I remember he he was so
awkward and so socially awkward when
they were having a conversation with him
I guess prior to that Sunday where he
was about to do a sermon he they kind of
mentioned that a lot of kids weren't
connecting with him very well obviously
yeah and that you know Jesus I say
n-word all the time I said like I need a
[ __ ] [ __ ] all the time no he um I
guess they had a conversation I thought
it was so socially awkward of him so the
the next Sunday I guess after they had
that conversation with them damn what
the [ __ ] hot rod but there was he comes
out and the beginning of the sermon he
just goes I try so hard and he's crying
crying all the youth he wanted he's
trying so hard to port
yeah and he just sort of bawling in
front of us I was like dude this is
super inappropriate bro all right guys
before we continue just to let you know
genius brain was brought to you by
Skillshare that's right Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 25,000 classes in design
business anymore you'll discover
countless ways to feel your curiosity
creativity and career so check this out
you could take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing or even illustration so whether
you're looking to discover a new passion
start a side hustle or gain new
professional skills Skillshare is there
to keep you learning and thriving you
know so what the reason why I like
Skillshare a lot is because and I
mentioned this before I'm somebody who
likes to learn on my own terms so when
I'm kind of put into a setting where I'm
forced to learn a certain curriculum a
certain way on their schedule I [ __ ]
hate it yeah so what I like to do is
specifically with Skillshare for me I
was in the photography yeah so they have
a lot of courses on how to start up
photography or just a lot of skill sets
that I kind of forgot that I had or that
I need to get back into again and that's
why I love Skillshare for that's really
cool so you guys can join the millions
of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for the genius brain listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
right my friend Skillshare is offering
genius brain listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 25,000 classes
for free that's right so to sign up go
to Skillshare calm slash brain be are a
I am okay again Skillshare calm slash
brain and start your two months free
that's right now at Skillshare calm
slash b ra i and do it now and develop
your skills oh hey this is really a
brother program and kind of [ __ ] up
right yeah yeah me at the seventy no
telling that to a [ __ ] adult like
there's a very inappropriate like what
are you doing dude was that when you
were working with the church as well to
know this is when i was i was just
attending the church as a regular ask
can you imagine this guy's research
during the week like he [ __ ] does so
much homework on what is cool he's
watching Saved by the Bell
[Music]
he's like this is what the youth like
these are what a chill do this is what
they use like a children and then he
prepares a sermon and all this [ __ ] he's
like rewinding the tape it's like that's
what I'm gonna do I remember screech
it's like the pastor that'll listen to
one really popular hip-hop song but
he'll change it to a Christian song
ahead he'll get like Tupac hit him up
but put it with Christian lyrics and
[ __ ] it's like bro you should've did
that you probably have a horse that's
why I love your [ __ ]
you hate satan head
that dude was so lucky we had so many
you gotta find him you gotta find him on
the show you gotta hire him just to do a
sermon for your show it's it's weird
because we would filter through so many
weird pastors passes are weird though oh
yeah so many for sure they're lighted
there like failed stand-up comedians and
philosophers and [ __ ] oh for sure dude
that was my uncle's a pastor dude he and
pastors love to just talk all [ __ ]
yeah like they can't turn off their
pastor ISM like even when you're in a
conversation they have to start
lecturing and you're like yo you're not
on the [ __ ] podium right now just
chill do people say I think like a
biggest thing the biggest worry that a
lot of people have when they when they
marry a pastor is that their family life
is gonna be [ __ ] up because they say
that a pastor always gives all of his
love and attention to his what a sheep
or flock or his congregation but he
forgets to do that at home because he's
so exhausted ah so a lot of like Korean
people they don't they love pastor's
right in like a Korean Church they
Revere the pastor at such a high level
they love them they respect them but if
the pastor's gonna marry one of their
kids they go no I don't want you to
marry one of my kids you won't have time
for my kids because you won't be a good
father and they're usually broke yeah no
I want you I want you to marry a doctor
a CEO or anything but just go to church
but don't marry that ya asked her yeah
what do you think no like who would want
to be a pastor though this seems like
such a it's a hard job field job I was a
youth minister for two years okay did
you want to become a pastor is that why
you rotated in those steps I gotta
follow in your dad's footsteps you know
what it is I I i'd like even like on my
channel i think for us to like you you
teach keep things in a you know teaching
bet things in a bad way you know right
yeah we kind of passed the rice [ __ ] yes
we do our own version right and i and i
think i wanted to connect with these
kids with in a way that a lot of other
pastors wouldd yeah and so it's not like
I would in well euthanize I didn't curse
at once at all like I didn't do it yeah
or so I know so [ __ ] saves a [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] that formal right out on him
but yeah I just I thought it was
something that I wanted to do and then I
find out I [ __ ] hate kids
and so [ __ ] little shits dude not not
all of them but there was there was just
a handful of them they were just [ __ ]
losers and
to beat the [ __ ] out of them in the name
of the Lord and all I could think about
was this is not for me yeah what am i
[ __ ] gang banging on these [ __ ]
little kids you know but it got to a
point where I realize like oh this is
this is not for me like you really have
to be somebody that's willing to be
[ __ ] criticized all the time whether
you do something good or wrong it
doesn't matter and everybody blames you
for everything you're basically doing
the same [ __ ] it's entertainment there's
a lot of [ __ ] kids yeah you're
constantly being criticized that's true
and they pay you more but you know what
I think the difference is you don't have
anybody watching you and telling you how
you can do this what you can't do yeah
at the end of the day you're just in
control of your own actions oh for sure
dude let me tell you this [ __ ] though
this is like some wild [ __ ] when I went
to when I was so this long story short
my dad started up this church in
Sacramento and they needed a youth
minister I wasn't I wasn't ordained or
anything else like that but I was gonna
go through like seminary school and [ __ ]
like that so they have something called
the tongue goes out which is like a
pastor in training and so that was me I
kind of stepped and I started doing
Bible study and then that later on led
to me thinking oh [ __ ] maybe I want to
be a minister so after a while I mean
they obviously weren't paying me very
well they didn't have a lot of money and
that was understandable but I got bills
to pay so I have to work another job and
they wanted me full-time but they
weren't gonna pay me enough so I could
live I think this it doesn't work like
that for me yeah and so I decided okay
well I'm gonna I have to leave this
church and a lot of the kids I like them
a lot I connected with them a lot this
pastor so [ __ ] fascinating so after I
left the church there was a whole cake
that was given to me people were crying
whatever I left and I would get calls
from saying hey like I want you to come
back you know and I was like I can't
unless you can give me more money
because I can't survive off of that and
then lo and behold a few years later so
you guys know ray we just met him today
yeah so Ray's parents still attend in
that church and Ray's parents told ray
that there was a story about me going on
in the church that when I left I cursed
out the pastor and I like [ __ ] threw
[ __ ] at him and so he when I left he
spread a rumor around the church that
way I left on very bad terms at the time
on Christian like how unclean and I was
livid because I gave everything to that
church he violated one of the Ten
Commandments I know I thought Allah
I hope Satan [ __ ] him in the ass you
want to hear some more [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that's crazy
check this [ __ ] out so you know I made
[ __ ] he made [ __ ] up and he made me look
like a villain as if I just just a bad
in the church and I and I contacted that
his ego was personally you like [ __ ]
burst it so my dad actually decided to
leave that church before I left because
there was an issue that was going on
with it were that pastor when he came in
he touted that he had all these
credentials right so of masters or
whatever in theology is all the other
sort of [ __ ] and he had he basically
passes in a few other churches churches
so my dad was like okay well we need to
see proof yeah and so he they they let
him come in people like them a lot but
then my dad he thought it was a little
fishy he goes okay well I need to see
your degrees or whatever your matter he
was basically a con artist he was a con
artist yeah and so wouldn't show it and
then he was like I don't understand why
you're you know basically grilling me
and my my dad and him basically but it
had this is a church my dad started and
my dad was one of the he left his own so
my dad was like you know what this is
not worth it my dad left his own it
should have been a title you'll do yeah
element I almost feel like God will
enter the righteous one and if they
should have a [ __ ] kick off bring so
many boards I know
dough I would have loved that [ __ ] so it
gets even crazier so my dad mentioned
this to me right later on I actually
found out that that pastor left that
church and that church is now closed
down because he borrowed like 30 or 40
grand from all that all the congregation
and there and by the way our church did
not have a people with a lot of money
yeah he took all that money and bounced
to movies Chicago yeah I met like
artists really get attracted to churches
because that was my fall of course dude
that broke up my last church that I went
to in hostel really yeah a con artist
came in and he started stirring [ __ ] up
and he ended up starting his own church
pulled away got split up friends that's
been friends do my um 30 plus years like
we're talking about like if you know
anything about like Church and Asian
culture a lot of it isn't it's like they
didn't have Facebook in a way to connect
mmm so sticking with the church was like
your second family yeah you know and
then I'm talking about like my mom went
to call
back in Japan with some of these people
they're lifelong friends hell yeah and
he came in he stirred the [ __ ] pot
like crazy he took away like several
members they don't talk anymore and
they've been friends for a long time
this fool ended up conning siphoning a
lot of money from the members doing all
this [ __ ]
yeah dude and everyone was like don't
leave don't go and they're like nah like
this place is bad and and it was it was
pretty crazy dude but that guy targeted
like I guess he's done this before to
another Japanese yeah
congregation and people were warning our
church like watch out for this
[ __ ] dude he breaks up churches
and then he basically manipulates people
and that's [ __ ] crazy dude you know
what's so funny like till this day you
know I tell this story and I never
thought about item as a Connor he is a
con artist that's a straight-up con
artist yeah holy [ __ ] yeah well [ __ ]
that guy do so that now my thing is like
if I ever see that dude in person i'ma
[ __ ] his ass up because and you know
what it's so funny because might when my
dad when I told my dad about this I look
you know what I found out about that
church and what the pastor's at my dad
just smiled he goes oh yeah me Mom he
was like people didn't want to listen to
me I told him I felt really bad about
him he wouldn't show me his credentials
he didn't show and my dad was like I've
been tricked enough in my life to know
when somebody's [ __ ] around and my
dad took the high road and he decides
just to lead the church and let them
just do it but he abandoned his flock
yeah but I think like you know cuz you
know how it is with like Asian cultures
you have to go at that point yeah what
are you gonna get they always just
follow the most charismatic and nicest
person yeah and if you don't have the
time to give attention to the people
they follow whoever is the most yeah
they're very impressionable man they
don't worry sure if they don't see it
off the job let's say do you know what
they should have just I just you should
have known he was evil based on how ugly
his daughter was hey his daughter you
want to talk about God is fair and just
dude I've never seen the most ugliest
woman in my life look like so she looked
like the dad if her Faceman half melted
off in the sun oh my sweat her like when
I was a little bit above the other one
her nose
a little crooked and she looked like a
mr. Potato Head after mr. potato sneeze
like that's what she looked like [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
all right and I'm gonna tell you
something right now to find her you got
to find her too he had to bring him both
on here out of blood lineage she's a
[ __ ] - I [ __ ] hate her guts
damn that's that Korean saying when you
say like [ __ ] your family for
generations like [ __ ] you for ten
generations right he [ __ ] up some
people for her for his daughter to look
that up exactly did he piss some people
off I don't even know what his wife
looks like but [ __ ] that [ __ ] - hey I
[ __ ] hate that do you think was doing
the heavy lifting in like the ugliness
department do you think it was the mom
or you think it was definitely the dad
she looked just like the dad dad was
[ __ ] like oh he was [ __ ] hideous
dude he's Korean dude obviously yeah
hideous Korean people do that you know
yeah even though we have some of the
prettiest people ever no I didn't mean
it that way I just the [ __ ] but he
was a piece of trash dude and I had bad
there's just a few people that I think
my dad definitely got burned by a lot
and he would that was one of those see
that's the thing I think mainly what
pushed me away from the church is the
politics man is stupidity and the
hypocrisy there's so much you're just
forced to be in a room with so many
people that you don't necessarily want
around you sometimes but you just have
to get along with them and it's it's
like high school and if you like you
have to please them a little bit - yeah
and it's so much [ __ ] politics and
it's like fog dude I want to be around
people that I choose but that I like
it's why my dad - like even my dad he
you know he has a master's in theology
you know he was a pastor and started up
a few churches and even for him he got
so tired of just Korean politics he's
just like you know what I'm just gonna
praise the Lord at home he goes this is
too hard for me because the more and
more he gets involved he it's it's
hand-in-hand you have to deal with that
stuff yeah so he because he can't avoid
it and he's old now he's so tired and
exhausted he goes I can't do this it's
over it I mean drama just cannot escape
the church dude it's just the point of
it yeah I think even the Bible is like
that it's so much so for me - when I
when I go to church now I go for the
sermon and I'm there like a so we had
this after you get away from me
I mister singing I'm singing I missed
the speeches that winner
they're good yeah they just it's like
washes your heart yeah [ __ ] cleans
the inside and makes you think I'm a
[ __ ] do good this week and in three
days
go in your [ __ ] I don't know you just
[ __ ] and do something stupid and you
get cleansed again you know once a week
and then yeah the potlucks we always had
Paulo yeah we always had Pollux air that
was so good Church was good therapy dude
like I was going on Sunday I get my
therapy I come back out masturbating
good to go yeah yeah rub one out rub one
out of the Holy Spirit it's like God
thank you very much but please close
your eyes about to get really [ __ ]
ugly I know it's Sunday this is what you
do in the mission trips dude get going
out that was fun man the mission trips
that you it was it was crazy because
when I would take some of these kids out
to like basic nations how much like
Arizona on like Native American land
stuff yeah kids will cry over everything
there's no losers or my bro we're not
even in like Tijuana this is level one
mission really yeah they were just
really some of them were really spoiled
yeah I'm I don't deal with that [ __ ]
never got to do any of that I went to a
Christian school for two years
yeah I didn't know any I went going in I
didn't know who Jesus was
I don't know what the Bible was I don't
know I just because it was educational
yeah that's what it was for allegedly I
went in and all these kids were like
literally like no [ __ ] they say the
first thing they said to me was have you
accepted Jesus as your Lord and Savior
and I was like oh yeah and I was like uh
I guess like I don't really know and
they would tell me perks they would be
like you know when you go to heaven
you get to like do whatever what do you
want me to an apartment is [ __ ] is so
funny and I was like I was in the sixth
grade and I was like oh like okay well I
guess I will then like that sounds
pretty cool this is like a sweet deal
like that's how it was schools it was
called passing a Christian school Oh
what I went there for like two years and
it was like it was rough it was so rough
so they're just like let me tell you
some of the person right so basically
after 12 o'clock you can't use the gym
all the amenities and stuff like that
it's like cool is great yeah here's your
key card for it no and then on top of
that it's like I got I never got picked
on more than when I was in Christian
school oh I got picked on a lot
but also everybody just wanted to be
good Christians and it was a lot of fun
I failed all my Bible homework no wonder
I was so mad at it they were like all
right Jonah in the whale I'm like there
were explain all these stories and then
we'd like it was almost like a history
class but yeah like Bible studies and uh
I got suspended one year for copying my
Bible a crossword puzzle like I didn't
do that I just didn't do that good a
society for that [ __ ] and they suspended
me and then for like fighting and stuff
like that's what happened you look
fighting in front of the Lord in front
of Lord look at that DK call me a [ __ ]
and I was like you know what I'm gonna
punch you in the face I was like I told
him I was like I was like get PE I'm
gonna punch you in the [ __ ] head and
then he was like whatever dude you know
and then you punched him in the head
punched him in the head I brought em and
make I have these MMA gloves my mom I
was like hey Ricky's name was Ricky and
I was a Ricky I'm gonna [ __ ] punch
you and he was like like no it's fine
it's like you think I was serious yeah
and I punched him in the face and then
someone snitched on us oh my god dude
and then I got suspended trying to be
Christian like let me let me ask you
something
was he Blanco calling you a [ __ ] no he
didn't they didn't know like he
apparently you didn't rat him out cuz
you're not a rat well not you know I
would a rat it like I'm hollow so I was
so afraid I was like [ __ ] we're gonna
get expelled like that Jesus is gonna
kick my ass yeah dude it was so rough it
was really rough so Christians like the
the best part was the chapel like I
enjoyed that
oh yeah like anything they would have a
guest speaker and I was like this is
cool I never had a church experience
before but then like that's what
churches they like to do this one yeah
it was sketchy I like how in the
Christian school they teach hardcore
racism yeah sup [ __ ] praise the Lord do
you did you hear about Jesus you just
called me a [ __ ] you little [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah that's how it was like all the
black kids all the few black kids would
like kind of kick it with each other and
segregated like the mine or like there
was a Korean kids that would all help
each other let's just scream people
they'd love and then that was it I
should there's a bunch of white people a
couple Browns mixed in but that was
mostly it I've been in a couple
Christian schools that I got kicked
I didn't like it wrong yeah but then it
went to vital to that we went to the
same 100 yep
well which one is it it's called Gardena
Valley Christian school one elementary
he was like a fourth or fifth grader so
he knew who I was
could you was like all guys YouTube
these all these elementary school kids
they would look up to the junior high
kids yeah so they knew like the names
and all that and then the junior high
kids didn't care who the younger kids
were yeah so he knew and he remembered
who I was I just didn't know who he was
so when we met up one day to like just
chat about YouTube he was like so my old
name which is moment no one knows about
it he was like are you Joseph MoMA and
I'm like how the [ __ ] do you know that
name yeah and he goes you went to
Gardena Valley Christian school my
collar [ __ ] is you know that goes I was
in fifth grade and I was a year or two
two two or so yeah yeah he's [ __ ]
wild the world is in junior high I had
this best friend he was like the only
white kid they're not actually there was
more white kids but he was like the cool
like surfer kind of like your white kid
named Joseph we made friends real quick
because he's like you don't miss Jojo
right yeah and then we were like best
friends at the time and I haven't seen
his ass and it when Tim had his wedding
he was there and I was like holy crap
dude I'm I haven't seen this guy in like
plus 20 years that's [ __ ] crazy it
was a dope yeah I did a wedding that's
like six five now and [ __ ] I'm like I
used to be taller than you do what the
[ __ ] happened cuz I stole it from you
died no no I was tapping your spine
every time I'm done I took all your bone
marrow and stuckman mine did yeah but I
got kicked out of that school because
they said that my haircut was too wild
what was your cut I had a raver haircut
I had the bangs and [ __ ] but I I i truly
believe that that was kind of like the
last straw i was [ __ ] around too much
no it was when i was in seventh grade
damn you were Ravin in seventh grade
kinda always wanna be raven but then i
started to discover weed and [ __ ] like
that in eighth grade I went to San
Gabriel Academy which is a Seventh day
Adventist school that was my religion
actually and then yeah I was going out
here in San Gabriel but I'll still live
in
like in the South Bay but my dad had
work out out in in in the San Gabriel
Valley so he would just drive me out huh
we would I would drug I'll get dropped
off and then like after a while I'm like
man I want to go back to public school
like I hate being around all these
wannabes and [ __ ] and I had a lot of
friends from church and just childhood
friends that went to that so I felt
comfortable but eventually I was like
[ __ ] this I'm so bored so I try to smoke
weed every day at school and one day um
the PE teacher saw me go downstairs to
the bathroom when I was just hitting the
[ __ ] pipe and he was like Justin what
are you doing I was like holy [ __ ] and I
try to put the pipe in the back bathroom
about a toilet [ __ ] flush and he saw
everything and then immediately they
expelled my ass and I was I started to
cry man because like I was like [ __ ]
like I wanted to get kicked out and
leave but not like this yeah yeah I miss
all my friends and [ __ ] you know you're
gonna say Biden to them no they took me
like that dude my dad came to pick me up
and that was it he probably [ __ ] you
up didn't he no actually he was just I
think at that point we were at a really
bad low yeah and then so like you know I
was eighth grade so I was a lot bigger
so like at this point like I think the
level of how much I was [ __ ] up was
just shocking mmm and cuz right after
that I got caught for graffiti so the
police called him up and they had to
pick me up and then they just completely
stopped [ __ ] me up yeah they were
just too shocked to the levels of what I
was doing yeah and oh I also threatened
them that I would kill them while
they're sleeping I'm only gonna get
bigger you could keep [ __ ] me up and
then he was while he was [ __ ] me up
all straightening him and my mom was
like just this just stop like like the
separation between us as a family is
just going too crazy probably beat you
pretty severely then yeah and without
the love there was problems in my
parents marriage oh yeah I didn't know
that that was cheating going on and he
basically was disappearing for weeks at
a time I was so I was so like out of it
yeah so I think there was just so much
[ __ ] that he just gave up he ain't give
a [ __ ]
yeah so like yeah he just picked me
already checked out yeah man like
I use just like all right what do you
want to do you want to go back to public
school and I'm like now I want to do
homeschool no I [ __ ] it that's the
that's the interesting to where I think
when we always tell about these stories
and people getting like beat and hit or
whatever there's this other side to
where you know people wonder so well how
come you never like really you know
fought back with your dad was because I
got beat by us got love to so you can
you know it's kind of like if you look
at some of like geo and Bart's video
like Bart will punished I cut but even
if he punished it PACA still runs the
BART for Loving Cup yeah you know
because there were some people I think
in your case to do the other part know
he was a cold [ __ ] but you know
what your mom um no actually she was
worse yeah yeah yeah so I I mean I
actually love my dad dude like he he's
he was he was dope like I got a lot of
fun yeah like I mean you know we talked
about the beatings and [ __ ] but that's
only when I [ __ ] up yeah yeah it
wasn't beating me every [ __ ] day of my
life you know like like he was he was
fun dude because he was stay at home and
like he would teach piano and we on his
free time so you want to go fishing and
we'll just [ __ ] talk and fish for
hours yeah and then so like and then he
would be like oh like I have time you
wanna go to the skate park he would take
me to the skate park I'll [ __ ] skate
all day he'll just read a book and
she'll chill so like we would kick it
but if I said the wrong thing I'm
getting a [ __ ] punch across the face
or something it's just very one this way
or the other way yeah it's just it's
just like yeah and in like we would cook
together we would talk we would do
activities together but everything was
around art like music or things more
like activity more like we would we
would do stuff he wasn't a bastard like
he's just he was cold like he was empty
same with my mom my mom was very
circumstantial very black-and-white
right yeah it's like you're not even my
son like you don't exist to me cuz you
embarrassed me that's crazy yeah it's
very different so but my mom is
different now because of what she
realized well she grew up so the person
that you see today is totally different
from what I grew up with like your mom
when she walks into a room I feel like
she's like a Keeley's there's like
feathers on her [ __ ] shoes and she's
just floating around she's a happy
mother
I'm so happy she's so happy because I
think she's went so [ __ ] low in life
like she hit rock bottom
she's never wants to feel like that
again yeah because she's one of those
control freaks I think like you know
that tiger mom or that that person that
that wants to control the world around
them because they're afraid of
everything yeah so like the worse like
they're always afraid for the worst to
happen
and then the worst does happen your kid
you know is going to court he might go
to jail juvie you know your other kid it
has no [ __ ] care of who you like are
like they just they just want to run
away from you so it's just my brother
right yeah he's and give a [ __ ] about my
parents at that time her own mother
which is got kicked out of the house so
she was completely alone my dad and then
my dad cheated on her left right so
she's she's it's like for a person that
tried to control everything now all of a
sudden has nothing absolutely nothing
right so then being so [ __ ] depressed
she be in her room all she would do is
go she would do the bare minimum should
go to work come back she'll be in bed
all [ __ ] day and I'm just like what
the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] up mom and I'm
like cooking food I'm like here you want
to eat something you gotta eat you know
and I'm like [ __ ] I'm the one I'm the
kid I'm there that supposed to be help
getting help right yeah that I'm just
like that's why I think I did so much
drugs and I went raving so much cuz I
don't want to see my sad ass mom she's
also be my support my strength and I'm
looking at her like damn you're a
[ __ ] dick up her pieces yeah and then
so I'm like where's my support I'm the
dad now like what the [ __ ]
so I think that whole point she just
went through that [ __ ] and didn't family
started talking to her she started like
getting stronger she started realizing
like where did I [ __ ] up yeah I just try
to control everything I try to like I
tried to make everything perfect all the
time she was like one of those people
were like oh if you don't fit my image
of a perfect son you're not my son kind
of person hmm and then she started
really looking into the Bible tying his
back to Christianity but yeah she's like
focusing more on unconditional love that
doesn't exist in Asian culture
everything's conditional you get a good
grade I love you if you don't you're not
my
you don't know that [ __ ] from the
seventh-day adventists of Japanese
cultures a lot of rules right so if you
if you I think
Christianity the culture in general you
have to be Western first and foremost to
understand a lot of it yeah because the
concepts a lot of it is culture right
like it goes hand in hand white America
and the new form of American Christian
not Orthodox Christianity or Catholic
but the new American style of
Christianity yeah where you emphasize
love and and and a lot of that community
and a lot of that unconditional New
Testament kind of love that is very
uniquely American mm-hmm like in in
Japanese culture it's the whole cultures
about rules
yeah it's everything's about like if you
don't do this then you don't do get this
reward so the whole religion was based
off of like if you sin you don't go to
heaven if you do this wrong you don't go
to heaven yeah everything's negative
reinforcement right so on my whole life
and my whole structure was always do
this right or not go to heaven yeah
you're not gonna go to heaven you're not
gonna go to heaven I don't give a [ __ ]
about heaven I told her that she was
like what I'm so scared of him you know
so I think being she had to shame she
was forced at that breaking point to
relook in examine like why is her life
so [ __ ] up cuz she did everything
right she was she told me like man I was
a good Christian I did everything right
why is God challenging me right now like
it's not fair she's like I did
everything that I was supposed to do I
was a good Christian I was a good mother
and everything went wrong and then she
remember that the passage about Jobe mmm
how'd you know how he got hooked up Jobe
is like the [ __ ] God is a troll dude
odd-job yeah I'm [ __ ] job Jobe is a
character for you guys don't know about
like the Bible job is the characteristic
he kept getting boy addicted in the [ __ ]
and Christmas this will got like STDs
from head to toe for no [ __ ] reason
you know like who that is you you were
joke yeah I was jokers I get a break
like what [ __ ] [ __ ] happen like his
whole family dies whole like doc got
burned out yeah yeah the richest dude
yeah everything everything went to [ __ ]
and he's asking God why why why you know
and so she remembered that and then she
was like oh [ __ ] you know like I'm not
really being a good Christian so um
what's going on what am I doing wrong
she goes oh [ __ ] I have to accept
everything as it is because everything
is a gift from God
yeah so like when I look at my son I
have to see him as the perfect person
even if he's [ __ ] up at the moment
yeah and and so at that point that
started to mend our relationship and
that's when she started to appreciate
life because she's like no matter where
it goes like I'm alive yeah and like and
and and so she started to understand
what love is
yeah and I was like that's [ __ ]
awesome I think that's like the big
benefit that a lot of people get from
religion you know I think that's one of
the aspects that people like about maybe
like Protestant religion or Christian
religion is that unconditional love part
and then there's this concept of just
really thinking outside of yourself
which is just I think even if you're if
you're not religious that's just
something that you should learn in
general yeah I mean there's genuine
people that aren't religious that are
considerate of other people and you
don't need Christianity to do that but a
lot of people find it through
Christianity oh for sure though just
like these little gems that kind of
context right that's what it comes down
to yeah context of woods where it's
pretty presented to you so yeah it makes
it easier for you to be like okay I can
associate this rule with this type of
like mentality and it's easier to kind
of go about it that way right yeah it's
like basically teaching a human how to
be human yeah but you know I think a lot
of people would know how to do but it's
not it's not easy it's [ __ ] hard what
do you mean yeah but it's also easy to
[ __ ] up a human being I know a lot of
people you know they're like that you
know that just don't get it no matter
what your context is provided in because
it takes time right yes there's layers
like there's layers to their
intelligence like their self-awareness
like their ideas of the world and they
got to do a lot of
a self-reflection like I think I think a
lot of people don't think in they they
don't even think they just exist and
they react so whatever happens from day
to day they don't understand that they
have an ego that always wants to be
right and protected yeah
so they don't have the capacity to
understand certain things like if things
go wrong your mind is always gonna
create a story that other people are the
blame to protect itself there's no
reflection
there's none no they don't [ __ ]
because I mean there's no
self-improvement if you don't if you
don't do that right but no one needs no
one thinks that they need
self-improvement that's the problem yeah
yeah and I was my mom right so she
thought she was a good Christian doing
everything right why is she being
punished by God why are all these things
going wrong when she's doing everything
right and she realized she was doing
everything wrong yeah put it but it's
good that she had a story or some sort
of context that she could kind of yeah
yeah yeah I think those stories in the
Bible actually helped because people can
reflect back to them yeah and yeah I
mean there's a lot of issues I have with
religion in general but I also see good
in it too like it's it's like politics
right it's you can't blink it and say
like all of it sucks or all of it is
good yeah it's circumstantial yeah yeah
because once it's out in the in the
universe you can't really control how
some people interpret it exact or you
keep there's nothing you do about it yes
just the way it is and you just have to
take it at face value for sometimes I
feel like with the with you know with
atheism and stuff too like it's cool
like I understand it it's just a lot of
people I feel like people who are
hardcore atheist probably got burned by
religion really bad yeah cuz a lotta
atheists never talk [ __ ] about Buddhism
or anything which I understand just
because I mean look at my dad my dad got
burned you know I got burned yeah so
there's you know there's there's
definitely a lot in a lot of fault in
the individual and obviously like the
institution has a lot of but you just
take what you want from it yeah and see
what you can get yeah yeah I do think
those some some religion the culture of
that religion is a little dangerous
psychology cult yeah I used to work for
them he did like some wives for them
yeah
that's [ __ ] wild yeah it's not crazy
he's so [ __ ] weird too he's always
trying to read my emails and [ __ ] I went
to get out of here oh my god no but he
did he was like everyone's really nice
go from there I don't doubt that they're
not but they're you mean you're a little
a little yeah I don't want to be like
generalizing but they're a little you
know called people too they genuine like
generally attack people that they know
that will be able to absorb what they're
gonna tell them yeah so like I've
noticed too like my friends are like
they'll never come to you dude you're
such an [ __ ]
yeah you just you always skeptical about
should do next yeah there's like
predators right they're gonna go after
people that they know they can
manipulation to cuz you're looking
they're looking for broken like when
you're pastor right you want you don't
want someone that's balanced you want a
broken person to help ya you you want
you wanna those are the people that are
looking for help that are they're the
people that actually need human
connection yeah in support initiatives
right and you're like oh I could provide
you some guidance yeah and then [ __ ]
them over you know and then you have a
customer for life
exactly pastor moves to Chicago with
[ __ ] 30 or 40 grand and the
congregation's money that's where it
gets dangerous mass a lot of people are
desperate for help and just some what to
listen to them and here comes a con and
they're just like alright you look like
a easy [ __ ] so what's the deal
with Joel Olsteen what are you talking
about is he the prosperity gospel guy I
don't know but he's the he's a he's like
a megachurch guy yeah Church long hair
kind of kind of slicked back Hurley yeah
so he teeth I think if I remember
correctly if somebody could you know
correct me if I'm wrong with Joel
Olsteen is the guy that he doesn't they
call the prosperity gospel the
prosperity gospel is basically I guess
if I were to dumb it down it said if if
you want nice things this is just as
rudimentary as [ __ ] God will provide it
for you
through because you deserve it right so
you'll see a lot of people so my friend
it's like justifying your greed yes and
so a lot of great a lot of like Oh
Christians that I know just really
detest that right so for example I
actually just had a conversation with my
my cousin he's a pastor too
and few families a bunch of pastors yeah
so it's within our family and my cousin
- by the way hated Christianity I don't
know how I became a pastor but something
happened a long ways but he he [ __ ]
hated Christianity he hated going to
church so I some along well he became a
pastor I don't know I got asked but we
talked about Joel Osteen in this you
know prosperity gospel but if it's not
Joel Osteen but the prosperity gospel in
general you'll see a lot of people with
LA a lot of mega churches here do that
[ __ ] right so it's like oh wait I'm
praising God right I'm doing this stuff
so God's going to bless me but these
pastors are walking away with
seven-figure salary dude and and people
are like okay well they work hard so
they deserve that money but you are now
for somebody who is in a religion that
talks about not having worldly things
right and really taking care of your
father people within your congregation
that could barely make their [ __ ]
rent and you're walking around with
seven figures in your bank account so
how how does that morally make sense to
you like I understand that you can make
money right let's say you make a good
six figures for having a megachurch
which is great which is a lot of people
don't even make that money yeah but
you're walking away in excess of excess
of X's you have suddenly become a part
of the 2% and you could take money from
your congregation people who are tithing
10% of their paycheck when they can't
even pay their bills and you're walking
around with that many zeros and you're
begging how can you [ __ ] live with
yourself yeah you know what I mean how
much is enough at a certain point right
exactly and so what they're saying is
like well if God want wants me to go and
do this work then obviously he's gonna
reward me but that's very anti-christian
and so the prosperity gospel does that
thing was God's gonna take care of you
but it's an excess so for example my
friend I think it was dual Olsteen
Church and within that offering basket
right so they pass her on the first
offering basket and then they said well
if you're not a part of this
congregation don't feel pressured to put
the money in great cool but then they
had a second basket come around and I
said this this the second basket was for
his wife's Escalade they fill that [ __ ]
up and she gotta escalate the next week
shut the fish it that's what he told me
so it's like that's like a youtuber you
know when the fans like when you get new
things cuz they feel like well got it
together yeah it's like wish fulfillment
right it's like you like seeing people
that you look up to do well
because it's almost like your team is
doing well yeah yeah there's definitely
an appreciation for it you know but it
doesn't say me as it's just it's it's
kind of [ __ ] up when you mix religion
with it cuz get all religions I feel
like you're not supposed to corrupt it
with greed yeah or any type of material
lately like just Jesus for example like
if you're Christian you're a follower of
Jesus Christ right he was basically a
wandering karate master dude and in all
he cared about was the you know like
spreading the gospel like in doing his
miracles and helping people and he hung
out with the dirt of the earth yeah he
was
he wore a [ __ ] loincloth like I mean
you know he just wore like whatever he
could wear yeah so if you're a follower
of that you know you're kind of like
like that like like that one's the story
of that tax collector the greedy guy
yeah you're not you're not you're not
following him yeah that's what I'm
saying so it's it's like okay I guess if
I were to even dumb it down even more
it's like this so if if that religion
like Christianity is based on you
becoming more christ-like right so
following Jesus Christ like that's what
the religion is based on then that goes
directly against what you're doing yeah
it's complete opposite like I said he
was the traffic karate master yeah I
just go around teaching his [ __ ] around
and then on top of that you know if if
him if so quote-unquote Jesus is the Son
of God and he's over here not ball on
the [ __ ] out what the [ __ ] how does that
make sense for you then yeah you know
I'm talking about he's like directly
from the loin of Godman why are you
trying to ball out yeah well what's the
purpose what does that show there's a
show that this is what it really shows
to me is that what you're saying is that
oh if you do these good things all the
time Jesus is like Santa Claus you know
you you kind of check off all you were
you weren't naughty you were super nice
well now Jesus is gonna hook you up with
all this cash I used to cheese just like
Santa Claus a blood please let me pass
this yeah I see mm when I wasn't going
to Christian school I would pray it'd
only be to get stuff because that's what
the kids told me he's usually Santa
Claus or my doctor when I get [ __ ]
mad diarrhea the first thing I do is I
go God why me I swear to God I go to
church
we can take this diary away I'm so
constipated please he's teaching you a
lesson
yeah like don't eat that [ __ ] yeah
nobody told you eat [ __ ] 80 dumplings
you best why did you do that at Din Tai
Fung
yeah why did you get 29 different
dumplings hour and 20 minutes and I was
[ __ ] fantastic Wow
Game of Thrones - Jesus Christ yeah Game
of Thrones comes full circle yeah his
brain is probably Jesus Christ that's
what that's what we're that's right
but you buddy he just ditched everybody
though you [ __ ] blind bastard yeah
yeah mine anyways guys that concludes
this episode yeah we got a previous cop
podcast it got super religious - I don't
know why but anyways you guys can check
this out on Spotify iTunes all that
other [ __ ] super time stupid times and
then make sure when your iTunes give us
that five star Nick where can they find
you you can find me at Nick the ear on
Instagram you never post anyway so
there's a [ __ ] or you find my website
and Nick the ear comm personal training
by Nick himself yeah I could teach you
how to like you know little ways yeah
just just be healthy be healthy just be
a better you yeah so Nick Nick Nick is
the guy that we all train with you know
he used to be like an amateur fighter or
some [ __ ] like that do this watch that
arm look yoked this [ __ ] oh your dick
right now just put at the Edit screen
you know don't be like why so small
extra wide yeah yeah just I gotta take
like a coke can I sponsored by Phil's by
the way does coffee shout to Manny
Oh Manny for the phone today Thank You
Manny - Ashley - yang she's she's my
clients yeah thanks for never hooking it
up they'll actually you remember every
Thursday as Sunday's is a new genius
brain be interactive leave comments
below go to the iTunes give us that five
stars you know to check us out on Cass
Bach stitcher Spotify everything else
and I will see you guys next week sexy
[ __ ] thanks for having me on guys you
get the [ __ ] out of here alright